Let's learn English with one of my favorite Disney
films, all about cooking and Paris Ratatouille.
So the clips that we've chosen for you today are
really great for learning English to describe food
and for use in formal situations. So we're gonna
jump right into that but quickly before we do if
you're new here every single week make fun lessons
just like this one so that you can understand fast
speaking natives. Without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles! Just like
our friend gills who says that watching our videos
every single day is helping him to improve his
accent in English. So we're gonna help you improve
your english a ton too it's really simple hit that
subscribe button and the bell down below and
you won't miss a single one of our new lessons.
Right all of these can be used as alternatives to
I understand. Now learning native expressions like
this is crucial to being able to understand fast
English. Along with having correct pronunciation
and knowing about connected speech which
is how natives cut and connect our words
and cultural context which helps you to
understand all the jokes. Now in our three
part master class we teach you about all three
so that you can understand natives at any speed.
So you can learn more and sign up for that
machine up here or down description below
and it's absolutely free so you have nothing
to lose now let's watch the next clip.
Hey if you're enjoying this lesson with
Ratatouille then I know you're going to
love this other one we made with another
one of my disney favorites UP so you can
watch that by clicking up here or down the
description below after you finish this lesson.